people ask me why I do things it's kind
of like there's not one rhyme reason
there's like a bunch of different things
like one it was fun two I love
entertainment three I'm really
passionate about YouTube four I I was in
shock when I found out how Society
discriminates against men yeah and I
there's so much stuff that I just didn't
realize like even we were talking
yesterday how you were saying like oh
the women were used like there's so much
language in our society that takes
accountability off of women yeah and
even like even their media yeah the
media yeah there's so much that and I
was just shocked because I just never
it's like once you see it you can't
unsee it